[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
un site
[Musique]
bonsoir
comment changer le monde
allez je pense que vous êtes tous déjà
posé la question au moins une fois
en fait je pense que si vous êtes là
c'est que vous intéresse à notre
environnement
je vous en remercie alors alors pourquoi
pourquoi est-ce-que pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne parvient pas à changer le monde
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne parvient pas à
changer de modèle de vie en 2002 au
sommet de la terre de johannesburg
jacques chirac nous disait la maison
brûle et nous regardons ailleurs
vingt ans plus tard il ya eu des comités
des regroupements d'experts des accords
qui ont été signés des modèles
mathématiques et pourtant elle bouge on
n'agit pas certains parlent de la
sixième extinction des espèces
d'autres parlent de l'effondrement de
notre civilisation pas moi
je me présente je m'appelle alain néri
bourgeois je fais de la recherche
pluridisciplinaire et mon coeur
d'activité tels anthropologie j'étudie
l'homme entre aujourd'hui et 2050
mon métier ça consiste à trouver des
modèles de vie pour vivre en paix de
manière plus solidaire et plus heureux
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne passe pas de la
pensée à l'action pourquoi est-ce qu'on
est immobile dans mon métier
en fait je parcours le monde et je vais
à la rencontre des chercheurs des
savants des tribus des gens qui change
un petit peu le monde
toujours avec cette question en tête
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'agit pas
pourquoi est-ce qu'on reste immobile la
raison elle est double
la première raison c'est notre modèle
économique en fait notre modèle
économique est basé sur des flux
physiques la transformation des matières
premières la fabrication des biens de
consommation mais aussi le transport
l'industrie l'agriculture
tout ça ce sont des flux physiques et ça
nécessite de l'énergie du charbon du gaz
du pétrole de nucléaire chaque fois
qu'on utilise cette énergie ça génère
une pollution et concrètement il ya un
lien direct entre notre croissance
économique et l'utilisation de l'énergie
donc de la pollution
alors vous comprenez qu aucun politicien
ne vous dira on va faire va faire de la
croissance et en même temps polluer
moins c'est pas compatible
à moins de virer deux millions de
personnes et de les mettre au chômage
donc en fait notre modèle économique
basé sur des biens de consommation sur
des biens matériels des flux physiques
ça constitue une autre prison c'est la
première raison du fait qu'on reste
immobile deuxième raison elle est
anthropologique
nous avons peur de la mort pour le
comprendre il faut faire un tour dans
notre histoire et même dans notre
préhistoire
nous sommes des homo sapiens depuis
trois cents mille ans homo sapiens vie
dans la nature
et cette nature elle est hostile
imaginez vous vous êtes dans un froid
glacial
vous devez chercher de la nourriture et
en plus de ça vous devez vous pas vous
faire dévorer par les prédateurs homo
sapiens il a peur de la mort comme tous
les autres animaux c'est une peur
instinctive elle lui a permis de
résister à cette nature puisque la dure
loi de la nature c'est manger ou être
mangé
alors on a structuré notre société pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir survivre
donc comme on a d'abord confié notre
notre sécurité à des soldats puis à des
religieux puis des roi de droit divin
et puis des cartes nous dit l'homme et
maître et possesseur de la nature
alors du coup on change de modèle et là
on va confier notre pouvoir non plus à
des religieux mais des politiques jusque
dans les années 80 où la reggane et
thatcher proclame l'ultralibéralisme et
alors là on confie notre pouvoir notre
protection non plus à des politiques
mais à des financiers des banquiers des
grandes entreprises voire des
footballeur au lieu de les confier
peut-être à des sages ça c'est une
position mais vous êtes libre de penser
ce que vous voulez donc vous comprenez
que petit à petit on a abdiqué notre
pouvoir en échange d'une protection et
ça en fait c'est notre cerveau qui
fonctionne comme ça notre cerveau il est
à ces feignants en fait ils essayent
d'avoir le plus de calories possible en
en dépensant le moins possible et du
coup hommos homo sapiens aujourd'hui
ressemble plutôt à ça il a échangé en
fait son confort son pouvoir pardon
contre du confort et du coup c'est la
deuxième raison non pardon du coup on va
rentrer dans un cycle vicieux dans
lequel plus on a peur de la mort plus on
va confier notre responsabilité
et plus on va confier notre
responsabilité moins on a de pouvoir
du coup moins on a de pouvoir plus on
est vulnérable et plus on est vulnérable
puis on a peur de la mort voilà le
cercle vicieux dans lequel on est rentré
vous comprenez maintenant que c'est pour
ça que on
il faut pas critiquer en fait ni les
politiciens ni les industriels
parce que chaque fois qu'on désigne
l'autre comme responsable de ses propres
souffrances on abdique un petit peu de
notre pouvoir
chaque fois qu'on est dans le combat on
est dans la peur on est dans la peur de
la mort et du coup comme je voulais dit
notre économie basée sur des biens de
consommation constitue une autre prison
mais non seulement on a nous même érigé
les murs de notre prison mais en plus de
ça on a donné les clés à des personnes
qui elles mêmes ne savent pas quoi faire
de ce pouvoir
on a un peu un fantasme de se dire qu'il
ya des grands puissants qui dirigent le
monde qui qui sont responsables de tout
un tas de choses mais en fait en réalité
ils ont peur comme nous ils ont peur de
perdre leurs millions ils ont peur de ne
pas réussir leur vie ils ont peur de
passer durant leurs femmes peu importe
en tout cas ils ont un peu ils ont la
peur de la mort également
donc voila vous comprenez pourquoi nous
sommes immobile les deux raisons c'est
le modèle économique basé sur des biens
matériels et la deuxième raison c'est
une raison anthropologique
so what qu'est ce qu'on fait qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour se sortir de cette
prison
la première chose c'est qu'on va
commencer déjà par imaginer qu'il ya de
l'espoir parce que devant nous on
imagine qu'il ya un tsunami
et ça ça ne pète rhee fille comme les
lapins dans les phares d'une voiture
donc déjà quand vous imaginez qu'il ya
des solutions qui existent
j'ai pas le temps de vous les détails et
malheureusement mais par exemple tout
simplement on peut passer d'une
agriculture industrielle
l'agroécologie ou alors on peut passer
de l'économie à la perla conomie donc
comment se mettre en mouvement
la première chose c'est que la peur elle
nous a permis de survivre dans une
nature hostile
sauf que dans une nature maîtrisée cette
peur elle est trop forte
c'était un bon moteur pourtant une
émotion on dit émouvoir c'est se mouvoir
et mauvais réant latin ça veut dire se
mettre en mouvement faire bouger les
choses
donc cette émotion elle était nous a
permis de survivre il faut pas négliger
heureusement qu'on a peur de la mort ça
nous évite tout un tas de bêtises
parfois mais aujourd'hui dans notre
monde actuel
cette émotion allé trop fort taux qui
donc ce que je vous propose c'est de
passer de la peur à l'amour la peur de
la mort l'amour de la vie qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
en fait à travers mes voyages j'ai
rencontré plein de gens qui ont déjà
intégré le fait que tout est vivant
ils sont déjà amoureux de la vie dans
tous leurs petits gestes du quotidien
ils sont dans le sens de la vie posez
vous la question
chaque fois que vous mettez des produits
chimiques dans les toilettes où va l'eau
ou alors quand vous achetez un t-shirt à
3 euros
comment at il été fabriqués ou encore
comme vous achetez une barquette de
lasagnes à 3 euros 35 qui est passé dans
les mains de cette entreprise est ce que
vraiment la vache à brouter de l'herbe
pas sûr alors du coup on passe d'un
cercle vicieux un cercle vertueux je
vous propose des mets la vie parce que
ça va changer ça va tout changer
ça va nous permettre d'être plus
responsables de se dire bah tiens
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour
améliorer ma vie qu'est-ce que je peux
faire pour être dans le sens de la vie
et pas en sens inverse
est ce que je peut planter des arbres
est ce que je peux ramasser du plastique
peu importe vous faites certainement
tous déjà des choses déjà dans votre
entourage sûr que vous en parlait déjà
beaucoup
et du coup en étant plus responsable on
va on va gagner en pouvoir et on gagne
en pouvoir
on va pouvoir nous mêmes être dirigeant
et choisir notre vie et c'est ça qui va
changer les choses c'est la preuve c'est
ma première clé ces gens que je
rencontre qui ont déjà intégré ce modèle
là je les appelle des homos
spiritualiste ils ont ils ont cette
qualité là ils ont sept ce point commun
que tout est vivant
donc du coup l'idée c'est de passer
d'homo sapiens et homo spiritualiste ma
deuxième clé c'est que tout est en lien
de l'atome au cosmos nous sommes tous en
lien alors je vous propose un petit jeu
est-ce que vous pouvez vous mettre
debout s'il vous plaît un peu d'énergie
je vais vous demander de vous tenir par
la main s'il vous plaît merci je vais
vous demander
je veux demander de fermer les yeux et
de prendre une grande respiration je
vous demandais de penser à la manière
dont pourrait être le monde s'il était
plus beau comment vous l'imaginez riez
dans le futur comment pourrait être le
monde s'il était vraiment magnifique au
point vous l'imaginez puis je vais vous
demander de par la pensée de faire ce
cadeau là à votre voisin de lui
transmettre par la pensée ce monde
merveilleux auquel vous pensez et en
échange
prenez aussi ce que lui à vous offrir
c'est de sentir cette énergie qui est en
vous
merci vous pouvez vous rasseoir
si vous pouvez lâcher la main de la dame
monsieur en fait ce que je voulais que
vous sentiez c'est qu'on est tous en
lien
on est tous à la fois insignifiant est
indispensable on est tous à la fois une
petite goutte d'eau et un océan
on sait pas trop comment la vie est
apparue sur terre mais ce qu'on sait
c'est que il ya des liens je vais vous
donner un exemple sur nos lèvres dans
notre bouche dans notre tube digestif on
a des bactéries ces bactéries elles nous
permettent d'augmenter nos défenses
immunitaires
elle nous permettre d'être d'être plus
d'être plus en forme
elles nous permettent même de changer
notre caractère on en a deux kilos dans
les intestins
c'est énorme certains ont peut-être des
intolérances d'ailleurs et c'est sans
doute parce que vous avez des bactéries
qui sont défaillantes et ça c'est
notamment par rapport à des pesticides
qu'on utilise dans les champs qui
détruit les bactéries
donc on dépend de ces micro organismes
un deuxième exemple c'est une molécule
qui se trouvent dans notre coeur qu'on
appelle mb cette molécule est là en son
coeur un atome de faire cet atome de
faire il a été forgée dans les étoiles
ya plusieurs milliards d'années au coeur
des soleils et aujourd'hui il se
retrouve au coeur de notre coeur chaque
fois que votre coeur bat votre sang
circule et cette molécule
mb avec un atome de fer au centre elle
circule cette pole est culte circulent
également
alors difficile de comprendre le lien
entre une étoile et notre coeur mais
pourtant il y en a un
et en fait nous est très difficile de
comprendre comment on est en lien avec
le vivant de la même manière qu'ils vous
viendrait pas à l'esprit de d'apprendre
l'anglais où la géométrie à votre chat
va nous c'est un peu pareil
un peu du mal à comprendre comment
l'univers fonctionne par contre ce dont
on est sûr c'est qu'il ya un lien entre
chaque
chaque élément de l'atome au cosmos mon
troisième point pour savoir comment se
mettre en mouvement ce sera ma
conclusion c'est que on a besoin de se
regrouper on a besoin de se réunir tous
ensemble on ne peut pas vivre tout seul
isolé l'université du développement
durable c'est un bel endroit pour lancer
symboliquement ce mouvement se réunir
entre nous et penser que ensemble on
peut vraiment changer les choses
on a tous un pouvoir il faut le
reprendre ce pouvoir c'est gandhi qui
disait soyez le monde que vous voulez
voir soyez soyez celui que vous voulez
voir dans ce monde
et puis etienne klein disait une autre
phrase que j'aime beaucoup également
c'est l'avenir sera beau pour celui qui
a du courage le courage ça vient du mot
coeur alors ayons du coeur passons de la
peur de la mort
ah l'amour de la vie passons d'homo
sapiens et homo spiritualiste je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]